Well today I'm going to talk about
a little bit about Sydney Klezmer,
mostly about socialism. And then Monday
I'm going to talk about anarchism.
Uh,
so in 1864,
the first international was,
uh,
created the first international
working man's association,
a dissolved among a great dad,
a tension in 1876 and also under the
influence of the commune because of the
repression of,
of a working class movements in,
in most places in Europe and also in,
uh,
the United States.
Um,
I'd off a ta who had crushed the commune.
As you know,
a boasted in 1877,
nobody talks to of socialism
anymore and rightly so.
We are rid of it.
And nonetheless,
it is in the late part of the
80s and above all the 1890s,
the crucial decade that socialist parties
become part of the political scene in,
in Europe above all in western Europe
because obviously the Mensheviks and
Bolsheviks when they are later, uh,
created, uh, are quite illegal in,
uh, uh, in Russia. Uh,
and the growth of socialist parties
above all in France, in Germany,
in Spain and Italy are part of the
development of mass politics, thus,
uh, closely tied to the emergence of, of,
of political associations in which the
socialist parties would be a very good
example. And the increased role
of newspapers, party, newspapers,
and also, uh, and just in
general, the penny press in,
in Paris in the 18 I nineties,
they're 20 daily newspapers,
maybe even a couple more than that, which
is phenomenal. I mean, now there's what,
there's an Ebay, there's a finger
hole. Uh, and, uh, there was pneumonia.
I mean, they're, they're
three. And then there's also,
I guess the remnants of
Francois, Francois, uh, but
there's just a couple of,
uh, compared to what they used
to be. Um, and so, you know,
socialists proclaim themselves.
Internationalists and one of the great
questions as you see in 1914 as the
clouds of war, uh, gather whether
a socialist workers in Germany,
we'll go fight against
socialists workers in France, uh,
and socialists workers in
Vienna. We'll go to fight, uh,
the Serbs and the Russians,
et Cetera, et cetera.
Now you can get most of this
out of a chips, our wines,
uh, uh, a book, but just to,
to make, uh, a few, uh, you know,
fairly important points about
the emergence of socialism
in France and France is
what we are talking about.
And then I'll break away a little
bit to talk about Cindy colorism, um,
which could be almost
better done on Monday,
but then will work because I got too
much to say on Monday. Uh, and then, uh,
come back to socialism and
talk a little bit about Jones'.
Ya has here who a unified
the Socialist Party I n 1905.
Um, so, uh,
basically socialists and France and
other countries are divided between
revolutionary socialists and reform.
Socialists and revolutionary
socialists were, uh,
were influenced specifically by Karl
Marx. Indeed, Karl Marx, his son,
a guy called Paul Lafargue,
of whom you can forget, uh,
he introduced marks his writings
in translation I in, uh,
in France. And as you know, uh, Mark's,
uh, believe in scientific socialism,
uh, it was scientifically clear to him
that inevitably following the bourgeois
revolution, uh, the
workers of the world would,
would a throw off their chains
after having United, uh,
and led by class conscious
leaders, uh, seize power. Um,
so in principle,
revolutionary socialists did not believe
in elections and nor do they believe
in, uh, in reforms. Uh, the,
the general attitude of
Revolutionary Socialists, uh,
was that if you encourage workers,
your minors in it, uh, uh,
in Jimmy now or whatever,
uh,
to push for reforms or can participate
in the politics, in politics,
political life, you're mat, you're just
propping up a, the bourgeois republic. Uh,
if you do that,
and the other hand,
they get themselves into a bit
of a bind because how do you,
if you want to have a mass
following among workers,
how can you not work for reforms such
as the eight hour day, uh, which was a,
you know, classic kind of, uh, a
demand of, of organized labor. Uh,
how can you not participate
in marches on May Day,
the first of which was in
1890, uh, in France, uh,
in order to put forth,
uh, demands for a reforms.
Uh,
they also were sort of caught in a,
in a conundrum because they're arguing
that that following Marxists in theology,
that the situation of
workers, uh, was a decreasing,
was getting worse in France. Uh,
but in fact, despite the, the,
the long depression, uh,
conditions are getting better, uh,
for most workers, even though the gap
between the wealthy and the poor, uh,
was as always a,
was increasing.
So they're kind of caught in a bind.
A,
their tactics are to
organize workers, uh, to,
uh,
make them aware of themselves as a class
a and make them aware of politics and
engage their,
their revolutionary activity for a
future date when everything would,
would, would, uh, when the revolution
that they, that they expected to come, uh,
would, um, we would follow
and remember, I mean,
we live in a time now where
you don't expect revolution
to come when people just,
you a racing down to the town hall. Uh,
or to the prefecture and overthrowing, uh,
uh, the government. Uh, but if you had,
if you grew up in a country in France
in which your grandparents could,
could talk, if you lived in the 1870s, you
could hear grant your grandparents, uh,
talk about stories they'd heard about the
French revolution. Uh, you had had, uh,
depending on how you count them,
a couple of revolutions
during the revolutionary
period, you had a revolution,
1830,
you had a revolution in 1848.
You had an attempted revolution in 1851
in response to the coup d'etat and above
all, you had the commune. Uh,
and the commune I weighed
so heavily, uh, uh,
as a way of encouraging a militancy
because for, as I said before,
for for one brief time,
people seem masters of their own fate.
Uh,
and the commune did initiate, uh, uh,
for all of the, the quarrelling, uh,
over, over, uh, uh, uh,
over politics and over policies
did initiate a meaningful reform.
So this was a while. It was scary
for a, a conservative elites. Uh,
it is energizing for both people who
want to capture control of the state that
is revolutionary socialists and
indeed reform socialists, uh,
as we'll see in a minute.
But there means we're
different and anarchists who
wanted to destroy the state.
So, um, the, you know, the, there's
an amnesty for the Comuna, uh,
in 1879,
uh,
and so people who were forced into exile
or forced into hiding a comeback now,
um, besides his Paul of farm, um,
that is the son in law of, um,
if Lafargue is a l a l a f a r g u e
M Marxism was introduced into France.
Bye [inaudible] again, if you're on the
youth side of the week, which is now,
you know, this is sort of, you know,
super chic and it was a tourist trap, uh,
uh, and has lost most of its charm. I,
there's a plaque right on the corner of
the intersection of the two main streets
of the USL Louie, that, that, that you
could hardly see it. It's up on the,
on the second floor, and it says
that you'll get, was born there.
So he was, uh, a Parisian. He
was a born in, in, in 1845.
When they use, Sally was very different.
There weren't all these belts, you know,
ice cream,
rip offs and things like that.
There he was the son of a schoolmaster a,
he gave up his intellectual
pursuits because of lack of money.
He worked as a translator in the
prefecture, a of the sand in Paris.
And he became a journalist and like lots
of young smart people in, in his, uh,
uh, of his day, he read Victor Hugo,
he read Victor Hugo on Paris and he
became interested in, in, uh, uh,
the plight of the poor. Um,
he, uh, became a Republican.
He was sentenced to five years
in jail after of the commune. Uh,
he went off to Italy to avoid
a serving time in the slammer.
And uh, there he a read Karl Marx, uh,
in 1877 and he created a paper
that got Iti or equality,
which had a circulation of 5,000.
And you can multiply by about 20 or 25.
The numbers of readers per each copy
cause people read newspapers in cafes.
So the diffusion of, of newspapers
greater than circulation, uh,
statistics would,
uh,
w w would would lead you to believe
he wanted to capture the trade union
movement, which had revived
after the commune. Again,
strikes had been legalized in 1864
and unions are a legal as of 18,
uh, 81. He was a very
successful, clever propagandists,
which terrified, uh,
the middle classes. Um,
and he was called the red pope,
uh, by his enemies, both outside,
uh, the, the revolutionary
socialist groups. Uh,
and inside he was also called the Red
Jesuit because of his authoritarian,
uh, personality. Uh, he,
uh, was tall, very thin.
He looked starved like middle many
militants at that time because they didn't
happen or they didn't have any money.
So they're living from hand
to mouth the whole time. Uh,
somebody described him as is always
looking ill. Uh, an extremely pale,
a fiery I shone from
behind metal frame glasses.
And when he spoke even
about ordinary things,
his lips seemed to quiver with rage.
He was a powerful,
ironic speaker. But not, you
know, not a spell. Spellbinder uh,
in the way Joe has, whom I'll
discuss in a while, uh, was, um,
and so that's his enemies called them the
red pope or the, or the or, or the red.
A Jesuit.
He helps file fine.
A crate found, uh, the,
the first mass political
party in modern France, uh,
which started out of after a different
name, but it becomes known as, as the,
as the path to Uva Francais or,
uh, the, the French Workers' Party,
uh,
which begins with some hesitation by
from get himself to run candidates,
uh, in the elections in
1881. Uh, and they get,
uh, some, uh, some votes, but
he, the goals of creating this,
this party were revolutionary.
They are not reformist or
they are not to capture, uh,
the Chamber of Deputies
through elections and to, uh,
to make possible reforms that
are promulgated from, uh,
the Pallium were ball or where the Chamber
of Deputies, uh, met, but rather to,
uh,
bring about a revolution.
And his preoccupation with
creating this mass party, uh, uh,
did alienate workers, uh, because, um, uh,
because they want reforms. And, and again,
we're talking about socialist
parties and, and, and you know,
what the socialist parties wanted at this
time or basically what any kind of, uh,
you know, conservative
Democrat would want. In the US,
they're talking about things like, like,
uh, uh, better conditions in the mines.
They're talking about, uh, uh,
the eight hour a day they're talking about
a decent wages and insurance programs
and, and that, uh, a kind of thing.
And one of the interesting things
about the path Uva, this calls the POF,
the property, uh, well, it just, that work
here, they're working the worker's Party,
French workers' Party a is a witch,
which also suggests that
the role of personality and
all of this is they do very
well in specific regions.
Uh, but overall in France,
they remain in extremely minority party,
even within the socialist movement,
particularly because of
their unwillingness to engage
in electoral politics and
to be committed to reform.
I,
they believe that elections and
the propaganda of these big,
big posters that are read posters and
purple posters that are still in the
archives,
which are wonderful things to look at.
That these are to be
sources of propaganda,
to make workers think
about their conditions,
to realize that their class enemy
can be defeated in, in revolution.
And so the places that the Geddes
do very well are in the north, uh,
where you've got, you know, large,
uh, textile and mining industries,
they do very well in a very different
kind of regions, some similar interests,
but, but, but our industries, but,
but without the kind of, uh, uh, uh,
Catholic fidelity that, that the remains
in parts of the north, they do well, uh,
down here in, uh, the [inaudible], uh,
and then the have and the lea,
uh,
in departments like that and their
places in, in, in the south, uh, in,
in the whole that is the department
of busy and won't Pta. And,
but in other places like for example,
the most where the Socialist
Party was and still is very,
very strong and remarkable continuity
or they don't do well at all. Um,
so, uh, again, uh,
is always sort of on the outside
looking in even within the context of,
of, uh, of the socialist movement.
But one of the incredible things about
these guys about get and Bruce and we'll
talk about in a minute in a bubble.
John Sherman as a is there
on the road all the time.
And here's where the
railroads come into play. Uh,
the number of speeches that they
give every year is in the hundreds.
They're constantly going, uh,
uh, showing up, uh, in a town.
I once wrote an article called
Dilla Guy Holla at a conference,
contradict her from the station
to railroad station to the,
to the great debate, uh,
where they'd be dating,
debating people of other
policies and, and, uh, the,
you know, they're there, the,
they do the tour to false, uh,
uh, giving these speeches. Um,
and it's really in the 1880s in the
1890 [inaudible] that you really do have
this sort of apprenticeship of
the republic and the republic,
the apprenticeship of mass politics and
of socialist movements through these,
these debates. And that's what a confit
homes contradict. Wire is in France,
or just call it a debate. Uh, um,
a lecture followed by debate and a,
for example,
when I was studying a porcelain
workers in Lemoshe a long time ago, uh,
you'd have these guys like
Bruce and, and, and, and, uh,
Joe has and the other show up and
there'd be taken on a tour of, uh, uh,
of Limos and they'd start out at the
worst of, provide more about that later,
or the amazing, I'll do poop.
And then he'd go run and
see the, and they'd see the,
the historical, uh, uh, historical
monuments in this that has hit me,
happened to me. I mean, I
was there for a long time,
slipping in the railroad
station. Uh, it doesn't have
any money. Yeah. You know, one,
one day out of, uh, uh, one
night out a seven could, I
was so broke then, but I was,
you know, invited back and all of this,
this, this, this, this thing to get, uh,
you know, uh, an award I showed
him. He didn't, uh, uh, uh, deserve.
And it was the same thing. It
was exactly the same thing. Uh,
the tour was the same even though
I knew the place for a well.
And we started out having a pair
of tiff, you know, drinks at the,
at the main zone to put that as the
host of the people at about, you know,
about 10 30 or 11 in the
morning and, and, and you know,
by the time you make all these
stops, it was a very, very long day.
And the thing went on until
one 30 in the morning,
literally to one 30 or two in the morning.
And this is what the way it is now in
this and in the circumstances. Uh, but,
but the way then was even as much more
interesting because what people would do
is they would go and you have some guy
like GED show up and he gives us talk,
you know,
he's up at the podium and gives us talk
and there are hundreds of people there
and then the other people take them on.
Then you've got,
you've got a reform socialists,
uh,
debating with him and telling him that
he's really flat wrong about this.
You've got an air kiss,
inevitably standing on the outside,
passing out leaflets as in 1968.
Uh,
and then you had a social Catholics,
uh,
who were priests that believed that the
only way you could win back workers is
to believe in reform. Uh, and,
and they would be putting,
there'd be wearing their
cassocks and things like that,
and they'd be making their cases. And
this was the apprenticeship of politics,
you know, for very ordinary people. And
it was really what's great actually.
And I mentioned the same thing happened
before the Co and before the commun
between 1868 and, and before
the Franco Prussian war in 1870,
after the law and on associations was a,
I'm the people going assembly could
assemble the law of June 18th,
the 1868. So anyway,
people knew who get was,
but most socialists didn't,
not a believe in, uh, in again,
um, uh, most of the people who wanted,
who supported yet we're
industrial workers. Uh,
though there are many artisans of course,
and even some small shopkeepers.
And I said before, he does best in the
north and then with a textile workers, uh,
not with a, not with minors now. Um,
uh, he was, uh, you know, it was all
over the place basically. Now, um,
he found a political
rival in the early 1880s,
uh,
who was Paul Bruce.
I didn't write Paul on board to be r o
u s s e who started out as an anarchist
and who probably coined that chilling
phrase that I'll talk about on Monday,
propaganda by the deed, that
spark, that assassination,
that bomb, that would set off the social
revolution. More about that later. But he,
he leaves anarchism and he
becomes, um, he be, he be,
he becomes a reform socialist.
Very similar to an important, uh,
German socialists. Uh, Edward, uh,
a Bernstein who's name you don't have to
remember, but it was very important in,
in, in, uh, in, in, in
a reform socialism. Uh,
in Europe, he ends up, uh, in an
asylum at the end of his life. Uh,
he basically leaves politics and he
becomes quite, uh, uh, quite, quite crazy,
not a very clinical term, but
he ends up in a, in a, uh,
an asylum and it has a
very sad end. Uh, and, um,
he objected to GEDs,
authoritarianism in terms of
building a political party.
And he thought that the program of
a Socialist Party should append,
depend upon local circumstances and
should not be merely imported from say,
Karl Marx or should be important from
some, uh, uh, some one of the many,
many socialists con congresses,
wrangling debates between factions of
European socialists and all of that.
Now this was kind of an important comment
to make and it really influences the
evolution of socialism and communism, not
the, you know, this particular choice.
Uh, but, uh, when even after 1905,
when the revolutionary socialist and
the reforms socialist unite under the
leadership of John Show has in 1905,
you still have these tensions.
They go right through world war one,
between the Geddes who
believe in a hierarchically
organized political party top
down where the leaders make the decisions
and the decisions are passed down and
the reforms socialists who didn't
believe in the kind of authoritarian
hierarchical organization of a,
of a political party. I mean,
there's tension is still there is you
will get in world war one ends up being
minister of, of transportation or Ministry
of Commerce, I can't remember which.
So he joins the sacred union that
comes during the first world war.
But this tension between a way of
organization organizing, uh, uh,
socialist parties is still there
and it will burst forward again, uh,
in 1920 a and the Geddes end up being a,
the future communists, uh, with
again the same organization,
top down organization in
the 1920s and thirties.
So that with the Communist Party,
when the order comes from Moscow to
expel the intellectuals in 1922 and 1923,
they were out of there. Uh, and there's
this tension between, uh, the way that,
you know, the, the communist party,
again, democratic centralism, uh,
which is leaping way, way ahead, but, but,
but the kind of organization could
be anticipated in the way that,
that Gad wanted to. Uh, uh,
and the other revolutionary socialists
believe it was the way to power that
tension could not be swept under
the rug by this unification in 1905.
So what did, um, what did Bruce want? Um,
well,
he believed that the deads program wants
everything at once through revolution,
but the result of that strategy,
Bruce and his colleagues are
good with that. They got nothing,
zero Ho I, and therefore, uh,
the ideal he wrote should be divided
into overall practical stages.
Our aim should be, as it were, to, uh,
be immediate ties so us to rent,
render them possible.
So reformed socialism was
the politics of the possible,
and they damned,
they're revolutionary socialist rivals
as the impossible lists because nothing
would ever come to argue.
Argument went if you just followed them.
And so they differ in several important
ways. That is the possible lists.
And those denigrated as the
impossible is, uh, they, uh,
that the, the, the Bruce Bruce's,
the reformers said that local conditions
ought to be of paramount importance. Uh,
they wanted a union of all exploited
leader. I mean all exploited workers. Uh,
but that local conditions had to be,
had to be taken into consideration.
That is the goals of miners.
And because veal or in the north are
different than the goals of porcelain
workers. Uh, in some cases that you know,
or other workers in, in other sectors, in,
in, um, in the industrial
economy. Secondly,
they abandoned revolution as
a means of achieving the end.
Although many of their faithful believed
that there one day there would be a
revolution, but they are not
espousing revolution because they,
at the moment it seemed to be impossible.
The state was so powerful.
It's army so large and when
we're pressing strikes,
so absolutely ruthless.
As in the case of,
of the the big wine strike
in a wine workers and wine
owners strike you property
owners striking in 1907
or in the motion 1905,
where they'd gunned down a
workers throughout us without
the slightest a thought.
And third,
they concentrated on winning local
power because if you were going to do
something for ordinary people,
the way to do it is, you know,
you elect Socialists deputies
to the Chamber of Deputies or,
and you elect municipal councils that
you have a majority who are socialists.
Now the constraints on municipal
councils because of the French state,
which is still the case, we can go
on and on and on about that. Uh, uh,
it was, uh, quite, uh, quite a daunting,
but nonetheless in places where
they do win municipal power,
they are able to take what funds they
have and do things like create nurseries
for working women. Uh, and
you know, they, they can,
they can have give funds,
uh, to the Labor exchanges,
which I'll talk about in a
minute or these, you know,
may only to pull up. And the,
the, these sorts of things.
And so, um, in working class,
because it's universal male hoods and my
manhood, suffrage, uh, in working class,
uh, they come to power and there's nothing
that, that the conservative government,
uh, were surely it doesn't want
them in power can do about it.
And after the radicals, you can read about
that, Eh, uh, you know, in 1898 when,
when they, uh, there are
social conservatives or
social moderates, but they're,
and they're very anti clerical. But
when they, when they come to power,
they will also often have alliances on
the local level with the Socialists.
Now what this does is it serves to
leave the revolutionary socialist even
further behind because they're Fidel,
they're faithful are going to say,
of course I'm going to vote
for this socialist candidate
if we win the municipal
council. If the, the, the
working class suburbs of,
of x town are able to elect for the
whole town and working class majority is
socialists majority,
then we can have,
we can have concrete reforms and the get
really don't have an answer for that.
And they find themselves,
uh, you know, uh,
despite themselves participating
in these elections, which, uh,
and supporting some of the,
uh, of these candidates. Uh,
just two examples of towns, uh, well our
three or four, but the towns that they,
uh, sort of model, uh, uh, cities
that they, that they, that they,
that they take over the Moses one where
the socialist mayor as the reformers,
they do all sorts of interesting
things. Oh, bay is another one here.
Big Textile town were again,
part of it's a conurbation of
these two who bay right on the,
on the Belgian border. More song was
another one down in the share. I mean,
there are all sorts of them. Uh, a, you
know, the examples don't matter. Uh,
but this again is the
politics of the possible.
It's the politics of the practical.
And so municipal socialism is
one of those things that, uh, uh,
that it merges from these,
uh, these reform, uh,
a socialist a parties.
Um, and then I mean, uh,
it comes to, uh, this,
this is her key moment in 1890 is at 98,
98 or 99. I think it's 99 where, um, uh,
the first socialist minister,
uh,
is sitting at a cafe in a cabinet
meeting and it's a guy called the,
not Meta home, but me, the hall, uh,
the name you can read in and Sarah
[inaudible] book. Uh, and, and,
and of course the Geddes go wild because
here you have at an a cabinet meeting,
you have a socialist minister who is
sitting at the same table with one of the
butchers of the commune, uh, with a
former general who's the minister of war.
Uh, and so they said, well, there you
go. If you believe in reformist politics,
what you end up doing is you're talking
about propping up your bourgeois
republic. You're sitting next to one
of the butchers of the Paris commune.
There is your revolution. So this
increases the tension. But in the end,
the two parties unify a though they
can't cover over these big differences.
In 1905, well, Bruce, in any case,
was a most unlikely candidate to
run any kind of of a revolution.
He was a wealthy doctor, um, uh,
and his grandfather had been a wealthy
merchant. And this presumably, you know,
for many of many of his constituents
than an oppressor of the people.
And his father was a professor of medicine
who was a related to a bishop in the
Catholic church.
He somehow ended up marrying the daughter
of a Russian prefect of police, uh, and,
and, and Francis a relatively small,
you know, country in size. It's, it's,
it's about the size of Montana.
It's slightly bigger than Montana and much
smaller than Texas. He Knew Gad, uh, uh,
when he had been,
that is Bruce a medical student
at the University of Molten Yay.
Which is the second oldest medical
school after Bellona, uh, in,
in Europe. Um, and, uh, again, he
was a, when he was an anarchist,
he was convicted of a press
offense. And so he, he, uh,
he flees to Spain organizing a
small, uh, a socialist, a club.
Now he accepts class
struggle. I mean, again,
here is this or middle class guy who is
a leader of a party in which the most,
most of the, the, the,
the, the, the members,
both activists and simply people
who are a vote for them. Our, our,
our workers. And this tool brings out
another kind of tension. And inevitably,
I mean, without making this too
confusing, there's another, oh,
that there's another party,
uh,
that is created by this guy is y'all,
I have mine and I had in mind,
and we can just do the deal
with this very briefly.
Sroi why does he simply says,
look, how can you have a, you know,
you've got to revolutionary socialist
saying, how can you have a party that's,
that's that, that's reformist, this
properly with the bourgeois republic.
And then Joel [inaudible] that he says,
well, look at the Socialist Party.
Look at the leaders of
the Socialist Party.
Are they workers from the minds of Camo
or from the minds of Aza or anywhere
else? Or they textile workers or middle
electrical workers and uh, you know,
outside of Santa Tien, no, they're
bourgeois. They're comfortable.
Doctors like Bruce, uh, or Zanjan. And
as we will come back to in a minute,
it was a pull phone.
Filo was a philosophy professor.
And what we need is a working class party
in which, which workers will be, uh,
both the leaders. And the followers.
So they kind of split off.
And there are other groups
that split off too, but,
but basically those are the kind
of outlines of all of this now. Um,
just to, um, well by the way,
John and mom was, it was, uh, uh,
a t a type I type a type
pot and typographer and he
claimed that Bruce with an e
w was an opportunist. Uh, and so, uh,
he was more in tune with the
workers. Uh, but it, looking ahead,
you can see the same thing again,
the expulsion of the intellectuals from
the Communist Party in the early 1920s.
And this kind of suspicion of
fancy, uh, speakers and, and,
and uh,
and wealthy,
liberal or radical do gooders from the
middle classes at a time when people took
class differences extremely,
uh, extremely seriously.
And if you looked at the
communist party in the 1920s,
the communist parties leaders are
minors or metallurgical workers.
Uh,
and this was a story,
strong tradition to kind of kind of
remon reject these intellectuals.
Many of them became very famous.
Some of them very famous
poets and painters and things
like that is, you know,
your bourgeois, we don't watch you. You
have your only class interests in mind,
not the interest of,
of people who work.
And so this is a tension that comes out
again, in terms of the future history of,
uh, of the Communist
Party. And you can see,
you can see the sort of transition from
these debates before World War One two,
what will come next? Inspired by
the Russian revolution, uh, of the,
the second one of October of 1971.
So who are these,
uh,
send dickless and what do they want
it just to complicate things even more
sinned.
Klyce rather like John Out of mine said,
look, we don't want your
basic bourgeois leaders,
but more than this,
uh,
even though one of the main
syndicates was pretty bourgeois,
but even more than this, uh, we'd
also don't believe in politics.
The question of how to get from here,
that is the relatively miserable
condition of, of workers,
visa vi other people too.
There that is a revolution.
Like the Revolutionary Socialists.
They say this does not pass
through political engagement,
that, that, that is, uh,
the in merely a false,
uh,
a revolution and you'll end up propping
up the Bush over republic as with
Mueller Hall as, uh, the
minister, uh, in, uh,
in the cabinet of 1899.
So what, what, what do
they want to do? Well,
what they want to do is they
see the shop floor, and again,
if you want to think about this
as the mines, uh, they, they,
they see this as both the
way to get to revolution and,
uh, they see it as a, as
the future as well. And so,
uh,
the radical syndicate lists are very
involved in the strike wave from 1895 to a
1907, uh, and so cynical ism, uh,
sometimes in, in Spain and in Italy
is called anarcho cynical Chism,
uh, talk maybe a little bit about that
on, on, on a Monday or I probably,
I know I want to have time. So this
is here, uh, because of, again,
the decentralized,
uh,
at the decentralized aspect of,
that is from the shop floor.
Uh,
you build the bricks that are going
to overthrow on a local level.
Capitalism and the state and the kind of
relationships that people have in shop
floors, uh, on the shop floor are
going to make possible the revolution.
And they are simply going to, uh, um, uh,
the serve to, uh, to, uh,
to shatter a capitalism.
Now, uh, one.
And so one of the institutions that they
see as and which still exist in France
are called the [inaudible] to provide,
or the labor exchanges and
a border patrol. Vi was,
was a place where workers who came into
town could go in order to find out if
there was any work there to maybe get
a few cents to have something to eat.
They would sponsor dances, they
would sponsor, May Day celebrations.
They sponsored civil baptisms or mocking
the church as ceremonies by having
civil baptisms, uh, in, uh,
these, these labor exchanges.
And so they become part of the socialist
vision of how to get from here to there.
I mean the cynical,
his vision of how to get from here
to there in that they are local, uh,
a local institutions that
bring together unions,
which would become members of these
labor exchanges and serve as a offer,
militancy, uh, support
during strikes and, uh,
and as her family solidarity
as well. Uh, and um,
they are the idea basically of a guy
called Phil Know Pilou ta there and they
wore his, um, uh, his
mark [inaudible] ta, uh,
was himself bourgeois.
Ironically, he was born in 1868.
He died in 1901. So he
didn't live very long. Uh,
he was a son of a civil servant from
a clerical and legitimate that is
monarchists family educated
in a church school.
He was kicked out of his church school
for writing and anticlerical novel.
He failed his baccalaureate,
his box.
That is that the be exam that
you take after, after the, say,
after high school. And it used to be
only 35% of people pass, then 50%,
and now it's up to 85 or something like
that. Captivate, sank or something.
But it's still huge tension. Huge, huge,
huge tension when you take the buck.
Amazing. But he failed
the, uh, of the Bach. Uh,
but he'd already contracted that working
class disease that killed miners and
porcelain workers and all sorts of
other people. He had contracted TB,
tuberculosis. Uh, he was a journalist,
but he had to drop out of journalism
after 18 months for medical purposes.
Um, he, uh,
he emerged from all of this a changed man.
He knew he was dying.
And so when he wrote about the
dying society of capitalism,
he was also obviously
writing about his dying,
his death in this capitalist society.
And I don't know where he contracted
the disease. He did not control,
you could contract it and in various
ways, but he'd not contracted, uh, in,
in the mines. So, um,
he believed that only the working
class could regenerate the world.
That is not himself as a bourgeois,
but only worker. So here again,
he's very much like, like a jump out
of mine, uh, there, uh, and that the,
ultimately what you'd have is a
free association of producers.
They would rather be like an
extension of the shop floor. And, uh,
the divorced, uh, Troy vi, uh, the
Anna, it, the difference between the,
between him and the anarchists
with that, he still believed
in, you know, in, in, in,
in class struggle where for the
anarchists that was more, uh,
in which the working class was privileged
or for the anarchist as mostly the
poor against the rich. And,
uh, and also, uh, against, uh,
the state. Um, the board survive
created libraries for example,
workers would come in and read.
Uh,
and so one of them differences that it
made if you had a socialist municipality
is that the Socialists municipality
would give money to the boards, Troy vi,
whereas in, in a reactionary towns
or towns that have dominated by, by,
by a radicals or, or opportunists,
uh, in the political sense,
uh, then, uh, they, they wouldn't
give money to, uh, uh, to,
of the Boris to survive.
Um,
and so those are the cynic lists.
And as far as [inaudible], uh,
so, uh, you know, who was an engineer, uh,
his really contribution was to come up
with the idea of the general strike,
the general strike and the general
strike a, he calls it a myth,
a myth, not in the sense
that it doesn't exist, uh,
but a myth in the sense that that
is sort of overwhelming, uh, uh,
given of the possible, uh, that
can motivate people to, uh,
uh, to take, uh, a militant
working class action.
And that one day everybody was simply
put down their tools, put down there,
you know, put down, uh,
take off their work outfit and shut
capitalism down by simply saying,
we're not going to work anymore. And
the whole thing collapse. Is it? Uh,
uh, was it naive? Will obviously it
was naive, but this was so house, uh,
among others, a big
contribution to, um, uh, to,
to, to send a clear and
again, when these strikes, uh,
move from factory to factory
in towns likely Moje, uh,
in towns like who bay in another
places in Santa Tn, uh, you know,
there was a sense among conservatives
as among working people,
is this the general strike?
Will everybody, you know,
everybody shut the place down
and workers during strikes,
they would go from factory to factory
trying to get other people to go out.
And who knows that the
factory is up the road.
We'll go out and pretty soon Leone the
rumors of Leone going out and then it
shuts down and not, and pretty
soon you can bring capitalism, uh,
down with the general strike. It
doesn't really work out that way. Uh,
obviously. Uh, and the,
the what's called the heroic age of
cynicism that is of strikes of strike
movements. Uh, uh, it
goes from 1895 to 1907,
and then it sort of, uh, uh, shuts down.
Now how did you know, how did, um,
how did the Socialist Party
become unified in 1905.
And again, all of the tensions
within the Socialist Party do not,
are not eliminated, but the French
Socialist Party becomes a major,
major force in, um, in,
in, in French politics.
And that was largely through
the work of the Xiong. Shar has,
who I want to take a few minutes
to discuss now. Now in Germany,
uh,
the spa day or the German
Social Democratic Party is
the largest party in the
Reichstag by 1914,
but it doesn't make any
difference because in 1914,
Germany is still an autocracy
run by this or of mad cap, uh,
a ridiculous, uh,
extraordinarily stupid, uh, uh,
um, don't get me going, but
extraordinarily stupid. Uh, um, uh,
Kaiser.
And um,
but in France it didn't make a difference
because France was a parliamentary
regime. It, well,
you can't call France had
democracy because women
didn't have the right to vote,
but it's a parliamentary regime.
And Joshua is by his personal
charisma and intellectual energy.
I becomes a unifying force of the
French Socialist Party. And again,
in 1981, when Fox wanted me to home
was elected president of France,
the first thing he does is a
cameras. Follow them around
the Ponti on. He goes, ah,
and to pay homage to a
Joan Jonas. So, um, uh,
what is important is he creates a unified
socialist party out of these various
factions and he gives it a, an
employee gives it to it, uh,
an impetus and a popularity,
um,
and a wide range, uh, that would carry it.
Basically after his death
on the 31st of July,
1914, a carrot into the
19 and twenties and 1930s,
uh, beyond, despite later claims,
he was a bourgeois by birth.
His family had included merchants
and lawyers to admirals and a bishop.
His father was the poorest of the family,
although he had married the
daughter of a, of a, um,
a successful cloth manufacturer.
Uh,
he ends up having failed a business
with a rather small farm of 15 acres,
uh,
in the south of France.
And Johannes was born in
1859 in, gosh, Costco is,
is northwest of Toulouse.
It's quite close to Camo that mine and
glass producing town there and the turn,
it's beautiful.
It's also got some very nice guy,
Yak wines and there would be great
improvement, uh, over over the years. Um,
but it's essentially outside of the glass
works in the mines. It's a very rural,
a department of 50,000
people on the farms.
There were 34,000 were
small property owners,
12,000 tenants and sharecroppers
and 16,000 day laborers.
So it's your basic rural France,
uh,
in the process of being
slowly a depopulated,
he got his education because of a wealthy
uncle who gave him the money and he
went all the first prizes in school
and things like that count in France.
He obtained a scholarship to
Paris. This is rather, again,
like a Maximilian Robespierre,
but they were very,
very different people who wouldn't
have liked each other at all. Um,
and he gets into the cold, no amount of
superior here, which is one of the goals.
They call her the big fancy schools,
uh, in Paris. And he did brilliantly,
he was third behind [inaudible] Saul
famous guy and a forgotten schoolteacher.
He got his degree in Philo in
philosophy to becomes a teacher.
And that would be, that's what you
do when you get your doctorate.
Then you go on to be a school teacher
and he's a teacher. And then then if,
you know, now it's harder and harder
and France because there's a few jobs,
but then you go on to become,
become a professor.
So he becomes a lecture
and then a professor in
philosophy at the University of
Toulouse, which then, and
now is a very good place. Um,
he developed a reputation for
being a, a great teacher. Uh,
and in the philosophical sense, always
was trying to reconcile idealism with,
with realism. Um, if you've
seen photos of him, uh,
he gave a rather uncertain,
uh, uh, impression.
Someone wants distance is saying that
he looks like a junior secondary school
master who'll never get as higher degree
and will never exercise enough or he
looks like a fat merchant
who eats too well.
And too often he's a medium height and
rather square looking. Uh, neither.
He's neither ugly nor beautiful,
neither unusual nor common.
He had a nervous tick of the right eyelid.
He looked bright and indeed he was.
And when he started to laugh,
when he told jokes,
he was simply shake all the way from,
from the top all the way down.
Uh,
he was at first timid
in religious matters,
but ends up being a anticlerical
do not anti religion in any sense.
He was always embarrassed when the
subject of religion was raised.
He would get out of it by saying,
I assure you it is more
complicated than you think. Um,
he looked like a bourgeois,
uh, on holiday, uh,
in a,
you know,
a d app or some place like
daddy looked untidy in elegant.
His pockets were always
crammed with, with uh, uh,
with papers and indeed with books.
He'd rather big, big pockets.
But anyway, but he was a great orator.
Uh, people who follow those things.
We know we don't have films
of, I'm speaking, that would
come later. But really,
Leon Trotsky, who was also
just a great orator. I mean,
they were conservative to
the most magnificent no
speakers really of their time.
Uh, and there were a lot of good
ones, particularly in Germany, uh,
among all sorts of, of, of
political, um, political types. Um,
he, unlike a, uh, one of his friends
Viviani who took lessons at, at the,
at the comedy phone says and
practice them. Uh, there used to be,
one of my colleagues used to
practice his lectures, uh,
in one of the parking lots, and he
looked at himself in the, in the mirror,
you know, these rear view
mirrors. And, and I don't know
my father, but anyway, uh,
uh, Zaria is, was, was, um, uh, uh, it
was not like that. He was just a bar.
He was just a brilliant speaker. He
was born being able to speak, um,
and he could take his crowd on,
on,
on dizzying verbal flights.
Uh,
and the thing that you do was he could
unite people who Kay would come into a
room and have very different ideas.
Thus, the unification in 1905,
just in a personal side, the person
that I know that most reminds me,
those politics are very different with
my old late friend Bart Giamatti who was
president of this place long
before you guys were here,
I knew died in 1989 and it
was the same sort of thing.
You would come into a room with Bart
Giamatti and I often didn't agree with him
when, uh, about some things, uh, uh,
but almost always did and revered
him and still miss him terribly.
But he could at the end of the,
at the end of talking to them,
everybody would kind of agree,
at least the momentum to,
to find conciliation and,
and to,
to agree to this common goal that
they all shared was a fantastic,
fantastic experience. And when I
think of, Joe has, I think a bart and,
but your has could do that. And that's
what he did. That's what he did in 1905.
And so he ends up in the Chamber of
Deputies. He represents the tarn. Uh,
the mining bosses get
together to defeat him once,
but then he goes back and he's there.
He's there for always and
then until the 31st of July,
1914. Uh, and when he
spoke, people listened.
And when he spoke in 1905 in
all the years before that,
people listened and the Socialist Party
unified. And when he went on the road,
when he go, when he, whether he's in
business song or whether he's in camp air,
people listened and he was on the road
constantly. And he became a voice of,
of progress and reform and reason
in a world increasingly gone mad.
And, you know, on the night
of the 31st of July, uh,
when he went to write his famous
headline about whether France,
French workers should
follow into the war or not,
it was one of the crucial moments of,
of the 20th century.
And it was certainly his last,
uh, his, his last moments,
that's for sure. So he defended
them. Uh, he, he defended the, uh,
the workers in the strike.
He became a political dynamo,
really of the left respect
and even by his enemies,
because of his power and his ability to,
to take the bigger project
that was France, of course,
but was the happiness of humanity.
Uh,
and to see how we can best
arrive at that, uh, uh, that, uh,
that end, the most
admirable character. Anyway,
1905 for all the tensions, the
Socialist Party, uh, itself,
uh, uh, you know, relevant to
are revealed of a revealing the,
the mass politics of, of, of,
of the new era of the 1890s.
And the first decade of the 20th
century, right after 1914 was, uh,
essentially his work. And Monday,
people who didn't want to,
uh, change the state, uh, I want it,
didn't want to capture power in the state,
but wanted to destroy it.
And these include,
some of them were interesting people that
I've known, at least working on them.
Have a great weekend.